oggi sono qui per parlarvi di di natura
per parlarvi di biodiversità la natura
quella vera non quella che noi
conosciamo e che in genere vogliamo
attorno casa questa è un po l'immagine
che noi abbiamo del verde quello che
piace a noi col prato qualcosa di
generalmente abbastanza innaturale e
tutto molto ben ordinato non la natura
di cui voglio parlare la natura che per
secoli secoli per millenni invece ha
preoccupato il genere umano quella che
era una sfida spesso una minaccia quindi
la natura che l'uomo ha visto nei
millenni come qualcosa da dominare un
limite da valicare qualcosa da gestire
spesso da sfruttare l'uomo si è sempre
sentito per lo meno negli ultimi
millenni un po al centro dell'universo
lo ha ritenuto di essere la specie
vivente più nobile sul pianeta
la specie è letta la specie che poteva
sfruttare a piacimento il resto del
pianeta per favorire il proprio sviluppo
il proprio sviluppo soprattutto di tipo
economico
quindi c'è stato un atteggiamento lo
sappiamo da sempre di vedere o nel
vedere le altre specie viventi che con
noi condividono il pianeta come qualcosa
di cui noi possiamo trarre giovamento
giovamento per il nostro benessere per
il nostro sviluppo
lo abbiamo fatto in modi molto varie a
volte molto o abbastanza morbidi poco
violenti altre volte in maniera molto
violenta
vorrei partire dai modi più forse
divertenti con cui noi abbiamo usato la
biodiversità
quindi le specie viventi l'abbiamo usate
per esempio come oggetto di spettacolo
chi di voi non è mai stato in un circo
ora sappiamo che anche i circhi hanno
vietato per lo meno in europa di
utilizzare gli animali ma gli animali
sono stati utilizzati come
genere di intrattenimento di spettacolo
anche specie rare specie nobili che
condividono con noi questo pianeta
abbiamo usato come intrattenimento anche
per i nostri bambini a volte con scopo
didattico quindi se volete un pochino
più nobile però fondamentalmente come se
fosse qualcosa da osservare ed ammirare
è sempre comunque da temere la natura e
la biodiversità è stata anche per molti
ispirazione ispirazione per esempio per
l'arte per la moda
abbiamo tratto dalla natura tantissimi
stimoli e suggerimenti più ho messo
soltanto alcuni esempi
mai più di più forse così vari abbiamo
tra l'altro questo è un vestito che ha
usato jennifer lopez e si chiama jungle
si è vantata ad averlo usato due volte a
30 anni di differenza del 30 di distanza
dal primo al secondo uscito su tutti i
tutti i media cioè la natura vista come
aspetto estetico o artistico
non parliamo delle pellicce naturalmente
che oggi per fortuna stanno scomparendo
la maggior parte gli stilisti hanno
dichiarato che non li venderanno più
però sicuramente è stato un modo molto
violento di utilizzare le specie animali
e poi c'è la natura che diventa moda
moda se stessa qualcuno di voi si sarà
accorto per esempio che da un po di
tempo non solo in italia anzi direi
soprattutto in tutto il mondo
c'è la moda per esempio dei fenicotteri
avete sentito parlare della flamingo
menia la moda del fenicottero una cosa è
una cosa curiosa perché stiamo prendendo
un colore il colore del fenicottero lo
stiamo trasformando in oggetti
addirittura la posa del del fenicottero
è diventata un modello per per i propri
selphy quindi una specie che viene
utilizzata come ispirazione non è nulla
di violento né nulla di drammatico per
un atteggiamento un po curioso che noi
utilizziamo a volte poi utilizziamo
questi stimoli questi spunti questi
modelli addirittura per il marketing
delle nostre aziende per la pubblicità
abbiamo casi abbastanza antichi in
italia vi ricordate c'era l'aquila del
fernet branca cioè il leone della metro
goldwyn meyer
crodino con il suo gorilla più di
recente abbiamo le megattere questi
meravigliosi cetacei marini che sono
usati usati che sono diciamo richiamati
dalla huawei per delle proprie campagne
quindi la natura ancora una volta come
aspetto estetico sempre per i nostri
fini quelli commerciali tipicamente o di
sviluppo economico
poi esistono degli altri modi in cui noi
usiamo la natura e la biodiversità che
sono molto meno apparentemente visibili
sono molto meno visibile conosciuti ma
che di fatto sono per noi la salvezza
non parlerò di medicinali visto che la
maggior parte dei medicinali nascono
proprio dalla uso intelligente della
biodiversità ma anche di cose che
conosciamo bene è molto meno bene
pensiamo alla carta la carta che noi
utilizziamo comunemente è stata
un'invenzione o meglio una scoperta nel
1700 di come le api anzi in questo caso
le vespe producevano i loro nidi le
vespe ronnie imparato a prenderla
cellulosa dalla corteccia delle piante
con questa costruivano i loro alveari e
l'uomo nel settecento ha capito questo
procedimento è lo ha utilizzato a
proprio a proprio vantaggio
gli esempi ci sono tanti alcuni sono
divertente mi piaceva portarveli come
esempio vi conoscete il velcro lo si usa
lo si usa spesso pensate che l'idea del
velcro e venuta a un a un ingegnere
mentre andava nel bosco col proprio cane
e scopriva che sul pelo del cane
rivenivano venivano attaccati e
rimanevano aggrappati delle specie di
bacche dei semi che era un modo per la
pianta di propagare a distanza il
proprio seme attraverso delle delle
bacche che hanno dei piccoli uncini che
si collegano e si attaccano al al pelo
degli animali dai è nato il velcro
questo ingegnere ha creato un'azienda
che è diventata ovviamente un'azienda
molto importante qualche volta voi
indossate prodotti che sono risultato di
un'idea che viene dalla natura si chiama
biomimetica questo è anche molto
divertente chi di voi non ha usato
almeno una volta le scarpe da vela
quelle scarpe che servono a non
scivolare sul bagnato sulle barche a
vela per chi ci va o semplicemente in
giro per la città bene l'idea è venuta a
guardare
il proprio cane questa era un velista al
signor sperle ha visto che il suo cane
non scivolava sulla coperta della barca
a vela perché aveva visto che sotto il
suo zampe a varie polpastrelli e questi
paul passa lì avevano tutti dei micro
taglietti che servivano proprio a creare
questa aderenza da lì è nata una suola
che poi ha fatto il successo è anche la
ricchezza di chi se n'è accorto e
potremo arrivare fino ai tempi d'oggi
con i costumi più tecnici per il noto
che vengono dalla pelle degli squali o
meno sono stati ispirati a come è fatta
la pelle degli squali quindi tante cose
che la natura ci regala e che noi
utilizziamo per la nostra è la nostra
economia
alcune cose sono ancora più strane
pensate che si è scoperto che gli
andamenti di borsa possono essere
previsti meglio se si adotta un
algoritmo che lo stesso algoritmo che
descrive il movimento degli stormi di
uccelli in presenza di un predatore
c'è una minaccia e tutto il brano di
tutto lo stormo di uccelli si muove
secondo certi andamenti che sono
esattamente quelli che hanno i
risparmiatori quando si accorgono
pensano che stia succedendo qualcosa in
borsa quindi direi
gli esempi possono essere infiniti non
aggiungerò altri dirò che però il modo
più violento è più comune e frequente
che noi utilizziamo naturalmente lo
sfruttamento delle risorse naturali
risorse di tutti i tipi
prendiamo dal terreno i minerali
coltiviamo la terra in maniera intensiva
defoe restiamo peschiamo e tiriamo fuori
dal mare tutte le possibili specie
viventi sempre con l'obiettivo di
produrre beni e servizi per il nostro
vantaggio senza nessun rimorso senza
nessun senso di colpa e finora senza
nessun limite
nessuno ha mai detto adesso basta il
pianeta ha un suo limite non si può
esagerare
adesso basta di inquinare adesso basta
di produrre per il nostro sviluppo di
concepire una economia che sia solo
basata sulla produzione produzione poi
di cosa di un'infinità di beni che
troviamo nei nostri supermercati che
affollano i nostri supermercati
e che spesso consumiamo in maniera
compulsiva se non eccessiva
basti pensare che più del 30 per cento
del cibo che acquistiamo viene buttato o
perché è andato a mare in frigorifero
per che rimane ai nostri piatti o perché
non ci va più quindi 30 per cento di ciò
che noi saccheggia ma la natura
ritorna come rifiuto rifiuti infiniti
che non sappiamo più come come gestire
quindi un'economia uno sviluppo che c'ha
un percorso strano
un percorso che toglie elabora consuma e
riporta sotto forma di rifiuto
ancora una volta senza limite e senza un
senso di come dire adesso basta
questo avveniva fino adesso direi fino a
poco tempo fa ora sappiamo qualcosa sta
cambiando e non è solo per greta diciamo
c'è un atteggiamento di consapevolezza
che il limite sia stato raggiunto
pensate un limite che era stato già
annunciato negli anni 70 ci fu un libro
famoso prodotto da club di roma
lo scritto e dennis medio un ricercatore
delle metti si chiamava i limiti i
limiti allo sviluppo e negli anni 70 si
disse se continuiamo così avremo dei
problemi
ovviamente il libro rimase tra la
cerchia degli interessati a quel tipo di
materia
nessuno ne tenne conto abbiamo
continuato abbiamo continuato fin quando
oggi però alcuni segnali ci stanno
facendo capire che abbiamo raggiunto il
limite è comunque la misura è colma
direbbe qualcuno da cosa lo vediamo
piccoli segnali neanche tanto deboli
ricordiamoci quello che è successo per
esempio qualche anno fa con l'olio di
palma dico qualche anno fa perché oggi
lo deve fare ma non troviamo più nei
supermercati ma cos'era loro di palma il
banner è una per carità un olio
fantastico fatto da una pianta
fantastica molto produttiva quindi non
avrà nessun problema
l'unico problema che se ne produceva
troppo e che i contadini gli agricoltori
di malesia e indonesia pur di produrne
ancora defoe restano condanne ovviamente
molto significativi
tutto l'ecosistema quindi successo di
mercato per produrre non solo gene
alimentari detersivi shampoo
biocarburanti si usava e si usa e mail
olio di palma per produrre biocarburanti
abbiamo esagerato
oggi le aziende sono dovute tornare
indietro con costi investimenti
conseguenti a questa scelta a volte sono
addirittura le amministrazioni che oggi
dicono basta
il re la misura è colma il limite è
stato raggiunto pensate alla plastica
adesso le aziende a torto oa ragione si
lamentano molto di quello che sta
succedendo ma perché è successo perché
oggi c'è qualcuno dice basta plastica
non perché la plastica sia tanto peggio
di tante altre cose
ma perché si è raggiunto un limite cioè
oltre non si può andare
l'abbiamo scoperto che la stiamo
addirittura mangiando perché oramai è
dentro la nostra catena alimentare e
quindi bisogna frenare frenare il
frenare purtroppo è faticoso e a volte
come si sta vedendo anche costoso
abbiamo dei segnali però che stanno
arrivando che forse non sono ancora nei
titoli di testa dei giornali o dei
telegiornali pensate alle api le api
stanno scomparendo per me sono ridotte
in maniera catastrofica
le api sono ci stanno dicendo perché
perché l'agricoltura intensiva che noi
abbiamo generato per produrre cibo cibo
cibo cibo ha usato moltissima chimica
una chimica che ha ucciso gli insetti
quindi perdere le api non vuol dire
soltanto perdere il miele che già di per
sé sarebbe un bel danno ma vuol dire
perdere gli impollinatori cioè perdere
quegli animali che servono a far
produrre altro cibo
qui nell'immagine vedete in basso a
destra un uomo che sta impallinando
artificialmente i suoi alberi da frutta
perché non ci sono più le api che lo
fanno naturalmente gli insetti sono un
problema né net se ne parlerà sempre di
più oggi si parla di plastica ma posso
preannunciare che tra qualche mese
parleremo soprattutto di insetti perché
stanno crollando la popolazione di
insetti è molto diminuita gli insetti
mi rendo conto forse fanno meno simpatia
di tanti altre specie viventi però la
loro scomparsa per l'uomo potrebbe
essere una grande minaccia e già sta
dando degli effetti nella nostra filiera
alimentare
e notizia di pochi settimane fa la
fausta dicendo attenzione sta finendo il
cibo selvatico cioè il cibo che nasce
spontaneamente noi continuiamo a
mangiare e come dicevo anche misura
sovrabbondante ma mangiamo sempre le
stesse cose molte specie viventi e varie
sono in qualche modo stanno regredendo
verso una una dimensione che è vicina
alla scomparsa quindi non scompaiono
solo gli insetti o gli animali rari
stanno scomparendo anche dei cibi
importanti e ovviamente il problema più
grande di tutti al riscaldamento globale
è inutile negarlo sappiamo che le
saldamento globale purtroppo non lo
stiamo frenando e sappiamo anche che
questo renderà il pianeta inabitabile e
dovremmo anche lì capire che abbiamo
raggiunto il limite invece di dirlo e
frenare cosa facciamo
continuiamo con deforestazioni incendi
perché perché bisogna coltivare e perché
bisogna coltivare bisogna coltivare
perché serve il cibo ma per chi
pensare che la gente ha bisogno di cibo
c'è gente che non ha cibo e vero abbiamo
ancora 800 milioni di persone che non
hanno cibo ma non è che non hanno cibo
perché non c'è il cibo non hanno cibo
perché non possono comprarlo perché non
arriva da loro perché non c'è un sistema
di accesso al cibo ecco su questo
riflettiamoci a volte le industrie ci
fanno credere che bisogna aumentare la
produttività bisogna produrre di più ma
produrre di più di che che abbiamo il 30
per cento che lo buttiamo e forse
abbiamo 800 milioni di persone con fame
ma sapete che abbiamo più di un miliardo
di persone obese o sovrappeso che
purtroppo stanno mangiando troppo e
questo è un altro grande problema
e allora cosa dobbiamo fare lo sa se
stiamo arrivando al limite e abbiamo dei
segnali non più teorici non più da
convegni universitari ma dà segnali che
arrivano negli scaffali dei nostri
negozi che arrivano nelle nostre cucine
sulle nostre tavole da cosa dobbiamo
fare
beh ovviamente bisogna intanto cambiare
mentalità quella mentalità che vedeva
l'uomo al centro padrone dell'universo
deve cambiare e se voi andate a vedere e
la parola sostenibilità che un tema che
si usa spesso oggi
per dare l'alternativa al progresso come
l'abbiamo inteso fino ad oggi provate a
mettere sostenibilità su google e
mettete immagini per vedere cosa viene
fuori alla parola google immagini
sostenibilità viene un diagramma un
diagramma che è sbagliato ed è
diseducativo e che ci fa capire che
siamo ancora molto lontani da aver
percepito come è la situazione
il diagramma è questo c'è un cerchio che
è l'economia che è quella che noi
conosciamo c'è un altro cerchio che è
l'ambiente e quindi la natura
e c'è un altro cerchio ancora che la
società quindi economia ambiente società
e e quello diagramma ci lascia intendere
che la sostenibilità quindi la strada
sia quella piccola zona del mondo in cui
tre cerchi si sovrappongono perché è
diseducativo e diseducativo perché
lascia intendere una cosa sbagliata
lascia intendere che possa esistere una
economia completamente slegata dai temi
ambientali o tre temi sociali lascia
intendere che ed economia può esistere
anche in situazioni di disuguaglianza
economica anche in situazioni di
sfruttamento anche in situazioni di
violenza e guerra
l'abbiamo visto qualcosa di grave nella
relazione precedente lascia intendere
che ci possa essere una società che
sopravvive anche se l'ambiente è
degradato non è così allora come
dovremmo raccontare ai nostri figli ai
nostri nipoti a noi stessi
il tema della sostenibilità dovremo
raccontarlo con un diagramma un po
diverso peraltro un diagramma che è
stato raccontato e spiegato da una
economista inglese famosa vi consiglio
di leggere il suo libro si chiama
economia della ciambella lei si chiama
che tra ward e le dice l'economia quella
nostra al nostro sviluppo va
interpretato con una ciambella quella
ciambella bianca una ciambella che ha
due limiti che non possono essere
superati
il limite sopra o meglio esterno come si
vede nel disegno è proprio quello
dell'ambiente nostra economia
se l'ambiente
viene danneggiato l'economia finisce ma
basta poco basta
cinque giorni di piogge continue e già
si blocca l'industria si bloccano le
strade basta non parliamo i terremoti o
d'incendi cioè basta che la temperatura
continui a crescere e l'economia sale e
l'economia si ferma
e poi c'è un secondo limite è quello
della società occorre avere una società
che garantisca i diritti e che consenta
a tutti di poter usufruire dello
sviluppo e di avvantaggiarsi quindi
un'economia non limitless o unlimited è
una economia che ha dei limiti e che ne
assolutamente consapevole anche perché
sapete qual è la storia
il problema non è quello che ci dicono
dobbiamo salvare il pianeta il pianeta
si salva da solo il pianeta esista da
miliardi in centinaia di milioni di anni
ha superato crisi molto peggiore della
nostra
il vero problema è che chi rischia siamo
noi siamo le persone siamo il genere
umano il genere umano che esiste da 3
400 milioni di anni le specie sulla
terra vivono mediamente 4 miliardi di
anni
noi siamo a 300 milioni e non so se
possiamo ritenere di essere abbastanza
certi di poter raggiungere la media
diciamo in cui le specie sopravvivono
ecco dobbiamo farlo per noi se vogliamo
sopravvivere come specie dobbiamo
iniziare a vedere i limiti e non pensare
sempre che i limiti non esistano e che
magari col nostro ingegno la nostra
capacità possiamo superarli con
noncuranza
grazie
[Applauso]